لطالما صنفت صحراء المفرق بانها سله فاكهه
الاردن مئات المزارع الحديثه تنتشر على
مساحه نحو نصف مليون دونم اي ما يعادل
خمسين الف هكتار والهدف الاول منها هو
التصدير هذه المزرعه مثلا تنتج 240 صنفا
من الفاكهه وتعتمد على تقنيات الزراعه
العموديه وطرق الري الحديثه بدنا ناس
ثانيين بلشوا بالعمليه التسويقيه ويفرجوا
ميزات الاردن بالزراعه هذه درايه ما فيها
فلتره لاشعه الشمس فبتلاقي عنا الشجر
هاردنس بتلاقي بتشم ريحه الفواكه في
المشمش ريحه الدراق في وبتلاقي نسبه السكر
عالي جدا فيه مليون وسبعمائه الف دونم اي
ما يعادل 170 الف هكتار هي مساحه الاراضي
الصالحه للزراعه في باديه المفرق حسب
احصائيات رسميه
سطوع الشمس الدائم والاستغلال الامثل
للمياه رفعا من جوده منتجات الباديه
الصحراويه وشجعا على زراعه الفاكهه
لكن بعض المزارعين يشتكون من ارتفاع تكلفه
الطاقه والضرائب الاولى بدعم ما يدعم
المستثمر يدعم ابن الوطن اللي هو ثابت 24
ساعه كويس تحت الشمس تحت البرد بالظروف
بالضريبه بالمشاكل قاعده تواجهوا في العام
الماضي انشات الحكومه شركه للتسويق
الزراعي بقيمه عشره ملايين دولار
واشركت معها الجانب الفلسطيني لايصال
المنتجات الزراعيه الاردنيه والفلسطينيه
الى دول الخليج واوروبا وامريكا الا ان
اغلاق الطريق الدولي في المنطقه زاد من
الاعباء توقفت صادرات نال هذه الدول بسبب
انقطاع الطريق البري الموصله اوروبا عوده
الخط البري عبر الحدود السوريه التركيه
الى اوروبا راح يساهم في مضاعفه هذا الرقم
الى عشرات الاضعاف ويصدر الاردن اكثر من
300 الف طن من الفواكه والخضار لدول
الخليج وسته عشره دوله اوروبيه
ويمكن للمردود ان يكون افضل لو استثمرت
الاراضي غير المزروعه التي تمثل 70% من
الاعراض الصالحه للزراعه رائد عواد
الجزيره باديه المفرق شمالي الاردن